it's been reported pretty widely that
Mike Pompeo served in the first Iraq war
also known as the Gulf War Mike Pompeo
is a former Republican congressman he's
Donald Trump CIA director he's also
Donald Trump's nominee to replace Rex
Tillerson as Secretary of State and this
has been reported so many times that
it's not even clear to me when it was
first reported for example in the Wall
Street Journal last month it was
reported that mr. Pompeo after
graduation from West Point in 1986
became an army cavalry officer and
fought in the first Gulf War on his
Wikipedia page it says that he served
with the second squadron 7th Cavalry in
the 4th Infantry Division of the Gulf
War but it's been suggested by other
sources that the second squadron didn't
actually serve in that conflict and this
has been pretty uncritically repeated by
a number of media outlets the LA Times
reported for example that Pompeo
graduated from West Point in 1986 and
was an Army officer who served in the
1991 Persian Gulf War a New Yorker
article also previously said it quote
during the Gulf during the Cold War he
patrolled the Berlin Wall and served in
the 1991 Gulf War to liberate Kuwait
after the Iraqi invasion although The
New Yorker article has since been
changed because it appears that it was
simply not true
referencing that the article has been
updated to remove a reference to Pompeo
service during the 1991 Gulf War and it
has now been confirmed beyond any doubt
whatsoever by the CIA that Mike Pompeo
didn't serve in the Gulf War period Mike
Pompeo served during the Gulf War and
that's sort of what this is becoming all
about at this point
Pompeyo was in the military at the time
of the first Gulf War but the question
is who came up originally with the
widely repeated claim that Pompeo served
in the Gulf War because this is very
very widespread and in fact it's not
just media outlets
in a letter from about ten days ago from
Republican members of the House of
Representatives
the more than 50 different Republicans
referred to his five years serving in
the United States Army including in the
Gulf War and this might sound sort of
silly
it might sound kind of like a semantic
argument right was he in the war or did
he serve during the war but this is
actually a major thing to other veterans
and some of them even emailed me saying
David
even if Pompeo didn't start this rumor
even if Pompeo didn't foment this rumor
any respectable member of the military
current or former would recognize that
it's their immediate responsibility to
correct this out of respect for the
veterans that did serve and people have
been asking but what about the Stolen
Valor Act right that makes it a crime to
falsely claim military service awards I
don't know that it actually applies here
because number one it refers to the
false claim of awards right like the
Navy Cross or the Purple Heart and it
doesn't appear number one that any
claims are being made about awards at
all
it also doesn't it's not totally clear
that Pompeo personally has actually
talked about this publicly but what is
abundantly clear is that this is not
going to register with trumpets or with
Republicans if Pompeo didn't say it
himself it's not going to have any
repercussions and the real sad part is
Pompeyo has no business running the CIA
and he has no business being secretary
business being the Secretary of State he
promoted WikiLeaks hacks on Twitter he
has a horrible anti-lgbt an anti-muslim
record in his history the Koch brothers
basically owned this guy he's a clown at
the day-to-day level but the truth is
this is a relatively minor thing
compared to the other reasons that the
guy has no business serving and he's
gonna get confirmed that's the ad
reality of and of course there's a layer
of hypocrisy because I remember a Trump
slammed Connecticut Senator Richard
Blumenthal yeah over his service
Blumenthal got a bunch of deferments
from Vietnam and avenged
chillie joined the Marine Corps Reserve
right and so during like reelection
campaign of his they said that he served
in Vietnam which wasn't technically true
I served in the reserves yeah and Trump
said it was like a big sham it was like
a you know military sham that he
shouldn't have said that and for some
reason that's okay but Pompeo is going
to get confirmed as the Secretary of
State that's a double standard
I think they'll focus on the difference
that Blumenthal made the claims himself
although did he actually or was it see
that's the thing if it's campaign
literature they're probably vague it
sort of still stops with Blumenthal but
in any case there's no doubt that it's a
very very similar situation and Pompeyo
just I mean what while we're talking
about Pompeo during our vacation I would
have talked about this but we were off
he mentioned that a couple hundred
Russians were killed by US forces in
Syria earlier this year there's no
evidence whatsoever that that's that
that's true what Pompeo might be
referring to is that six to nine
mercenaries working in syria who
happened to have been russian appear to
have been killed but the idea that
hundreds were killed is not true and the
idea that they were killed sort of as
Russian operatives as opposed to
mercenaries who could really be from any
country I mean just out-and-out lies
that the guy is not being held
accountable for did you catch the
highlights from his confirmation hearing
I saw Cory Booker slam him on his past
statements on the LGBT community and
Muslims it was it was outrageous I
didn't catch it I tried to really tune
it out during the during the break but
sadly of no consequence
since as outrageous as they were guys
gonna be the next Secretary of State and
a total embarrassment as the top
diplomat of the United States today's
program is made possible in part by
fruit or which is a social forecasting
game for your phone where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you go on the app
find a future event you feel confident
enough about to make a prediction and
make a bet on the outcome that you think
will happen using the apps in game fake
currency if your prediction is right
you're rewarded with more points you can
compete with others who are making their
own prediction to see who is the best
forecaster there's no real world
money or cryptocurrency involved the fun
of futur is interacting with others and
showing the world your skills at
predicting the future will Democrats
take the White House house this year
will Trump run for re-election will
trump ever build the wall you can go
ahead and make your predictions show off
your forecasting skills and there are
also monthly competitions and prizes for
top forecasters and I'm on food tour you
can wager on my predictions you can also
browse the politics category for lots of
interesting questions to go to fruit or
calm to sign up and make forecast it's
free it's on Android and iOS as well as
on web browsers and it's spelled fut you
you are calm